this is not march 2020.
that's a quote a message from a georgia
mom
who went after her school board for
still requiring children
young kids to mask up and socially
distance
she said there's little evidence kids
are at risk of getting covered
her outrage is going viral
every month i come here and i hear the
same thing social emotional health
if you truly mean that you would end the
mask
requirement tonight
tonight this is not march 2020 anymore
we have three vaccines every adult in
the state of georgia that wants that
vaccine is eligible to get it right now
and every one of us knows that young
children are not affected by this virus
they're not and that's a blessing but as
the adults what have we done with that
blessing
we've shoved it to the side and we've
said we don't care you're still going to
wear a mask on your face every day
five and six-year-olds you still can't
play together on the playground like
normal children seven and
eight-year-olds
we don't care we're still going to force
you to carry a burden that was never
yours to carry shame on us
my six-year-old looks at me every month
before i come here and she says are you
going to tell them tonight
tell them i don't want to wear this
anymore and i say baby it's not time to
fight that battle yet i try to explain
that there's so many things
but it's april 15th 2021
and it's time take these masks off
of my child
[Applause]
kaylee mcanini it is visceral when you
watch that
your first reaction yeah it reminds me
of the moment uh
dr scott atlas walked in my office and
said what civilized nation
sacrifices their children as the rest of
the world
reopened their schools we locked down uh
and this woman is so right to show this
emotion especially when you have
an expert the panel rhonda santa's had
that got taken off youtube
an expert from oxford harvard and
stanford
all talking about math with children
citing data studies from iceland studies
from sweden saying this is not necessary
and it's removed from youtube we've
sacrificed our children
when the science is on the side of
reopening schools not wearing masks if
you're under five the who says that
we've sacrificed our children it's
shameful and that parent
you know praising her for speaking up
very well done